foreign
[Music]
ers
I hate to tell you but you picked the
wrong time to come to town
bet you thought your world was in chaos
try this on precise up bitten infected
somewhere between alive and dead God all
right I'm returning [ __ ] doesn't get
more real than this
[Music]
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hello
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting it's crawling with
Adventure and crazy ways to pass your
final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a train special
although we're getting the pizza
they're all as mad as the flesh eaters
[ __ ]
foreign
Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning or whatever it is they're gonna
really feel it I guess dreams do come
true
and [ __ ] man you'd be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
Tana's machetes swords hammers bigger
hammers are those bear claws and
naturally a holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
this is too awesome
oh and that zombie butt came with a
little pop of Z power
which is always handy
freaking zombies these reanimated
[ __ ] come in all shapes and sizes
we got big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dummy
noisy ones I hate the noisy ones even
pretty ones you really can't knock their
stuff
except for this guy back for more huh
hey Different Strokes for different
folks right as long as you're dead stay
dead
[Music]
so
what do you say
you in hell